credit tune bag Donald Trump both are
scheduled to attend the annual World
Economic Forum meetings in Davos
Switzerland which are getting underway
Monday a sustainability and climate
change are the main topics of the
meeting activists like toon berg are
putting more pressure on governments and
business leaders to do more in stopping
climate change
the forum is introducing a scorecard
this year to rate companies on how
sustainably they act now ahead of Davos
American money management firm Blackrock
has grabbed a great deal of the
attention of the finance world its CEO
Larry Fiske announcing that the company
would quote exit investments presenting
a high sustainability related risk in
quote for a start investing hundreds of
millions of dollars from coal linked
businesses now that could be a big deal
Blackrock is the world's largest fund
manager it holds close to seven trillion
dollars in assets to put that in
perspective Germany's entire GDP for
2018 was closer to four trillion dollars
now managing that amount of money means
a correspondingly high level of
influence in the corporate world in
Germany Germany alone Blackrock counts
as the biggest single shareholder in the
following tax companies Siemens Marek
buyer among them the question now what
could its decision mean for the broader
world of Finance and for more on this
I'm joined by Sasha Stefon of the
Frankfurt School of Finance and
management such it's good to have you
with us
this would seem like quite a momentous
decision from Blackrock can you shed
some perspective on this how big a deal
is it I think first of all it's an
important I think it's a big deal that a
black run all joined other companies
banks insurance companies and trying to
take specific actions the question is on
the one hand how they can do it and are
they actually going to follow up on that
what so I think the the question how
they can do it on the one hand they
could as I said are divest investments
but the amount of assets out of these 7
billion 2 billion are actually actively
managed right they can actually do that
the rest is so-called passively invested
and and this is very difficult to divest
so another important or potentially
important activity would be to
vote even with these passively at stake
and say support these climates neutral
climate friendly actions which they
actually have opposed during the last
couple of years has black rot suggested
with its new strategy that it might
actually vote on some of these companies
I think there's a question is are they
going to do that right because the on
the one hand this new approach or what
we called being there not only for the
shareholders but for general for the
stakeholders at large meaning also the
environment and other stakeholders meet
a complete shift from this a shareholder
focused model and the shareholders
usually also focus on more short-term
gain rather than the long-term
perspective though the question is is
Blackrock as we going follow through and
and then more broadly what is actually
the the best and most efficient way to
address these climate change problems so
she is there any sign that other major
fund managers such as Vanguard could be
taking a similar position
well III assume that once one manager
started the others will will definitely
chime in and we see also that not only
the asset managers but also insurers
bangs
are thinking more carefully about how
they employ their their capital but I
think more largely and and and the
bottom line is this is going to be
enough is the private sector really
equipped dealing with these large and
important issues or should it be and
this is actually my major point it
should actually be government's dealing
with the problem which affects society
lobby all right Sasha Stephan professor
at the Frankfurt School thank you very
much